Content creators have been the foundation of TikTok's success.
These users have access to a wide range of songs, effects and filters...
...to both create and share short form, entertaining videos.
These self-created videos are quick, cringeworthy and often downright bizarre.
A sharp contrast to most social media apps,..
...which tend to focus on highlights...
...or showing the best version of ourselves.
TikTok uses your past likes, comments and even how long you watch videos...
...or the speed at which you swipe away,...
...to curate your customized timeline.
And while other social media platforms use AI as a tool for recommendation,...
...TikTok is fully reliant on it.
It removes decision-making completely...
...and serves you the videos it thinks you'll like.